the way to judge to see if anything's
happening to the economy is through
shopping through 99 Cent Stores which by
the way these 99 stores right now are
being full again there's a story on it
which we'll read about here in a minute
this is going to sound funny but strip
clubs uh you know additional places
people go to you you can ask a lot of
interesting folks how money is being
spent you can talk to people who are
getting tips you can talk to a lot of
the are people being a little bit
tighter I talked to one of the top uh
baseball card guys yesterday the
baseball card industry had a Nationals
this last week and when the Nationals
happen people show up from all over the
place to go to the National just like
the NBA All-Star Game happens once a
year they had it this last week they had
some of the biggest cards on there one
of the cards right now that's on sale on
Heritage auctions they just reached out
to me to see if I'm interested it's
going to be it's a Mickey Mantle 52 tops
SGC 9.5 uh starting bit was at 5 million
they're estimating this card is going to
go between 9 to 15 million bucks
Heritage auction Pat is interested I
don't know is it one of is it one of
them like I assume you're interested
yeah I am interested in this but I don't
know if I'm gonna go that high for that
card is this one of the mantles or this
is one of the mantles there's four cards
of men there's three PSA tens there's
one SGC nine and a half this is one of
them and the guy that's selling you look
when he's selling you look when he is
selling it if he would have sold it a
year ago he would have gone a few
million dollars more than he would get
it right now so he's off in a market by
about a year the card Market is down 20
to 50 percent okay let me say this one
more time the card Market is down 20 to
50 which means guys were paying 500 000
for a card last year that card's gonna
go for three hundred thousand dollars
this year okay guys we're spending
thirty two thousand dollars on a basic
PSA 10 LeBron James card today it's gone
for sixteen thousand hours twelve
thousand dollars so that's a big
difference those are some of the stuff
that you're noticing but by the way it's
still early I mean if you look at what's
going on with the mortgages we have
record-breaking Equity right now okay
people are still sitting on
record-breaking Equity right that
challenge is with the folks that are
sitting on record-breaking Equity most
people are trying to sell their house
for a price that will not sell today so
you may think what is really Equity
think about what Equity what is really
Equity it's like a price on the stock
market that goes by and unless you do
something today it's just a price that's
going by so so so so you know how
unrealized gains dude like six that's
exactly right it's like watching a
ticker it's like when a guy owns a few
hundred million dollars on paper of a
company which I know a couple guys like
that when you own a couple hundred
million dollars on paper yeah and then
that's converted to Cash There's a big
difference between
because it's just like there's a big
difference between a paper and a cash
right so so a lot of people that are
like well I got 400 000 in equity I got
three hundred thousand dollars in equity
I would probably say the best bet if you
got Equity right now is uh try to refi
okay try to refinance try to no try not
try to refi try to see if you can get
them obviously don't go
figure right away if you can get a home
equity line of credit and sit on the
sidelines with that if you can do
something because if you can then it's
true Equity if you don't it's just you
think you gotta quit it we're not gonna
know what are people willing to pay for
that house if a person was willing to
pay a million dollars for last year said
950 today is it 900 is it 850 what's
that number we don't know so I think
we're still going to figure out the next
three six months what is going to really
happen every month the one thing about
winning and losing okay when you're
winning you know and you win for a long
time you think you're going to win
forever and you're not okay the thing
about losing is what but you're losing
for a long time
you think gonna lose forever and you're
not [ __ ] can turn very quickly good and
bad so if you're overly overly
optimistic maybe drink a little better
pattern now you know may not be bad for
you to get a little paranoid and if
you've been losing a little bit too much
maybe it's good you go about re by the
book Norman Vincent peel the power of
positive thinking and have a drink or
two of a positive thing and see what it
does for you but regardless of what's
going on uh we don't really know exactly
what's going to happen with the market
the next three to six 12 months we just
know the numbers indicate this is not
good well Bill Gates says success is a
lousy teacher and that every town every
now and then if you have a setback on a
product launch or something it's
actually a good teacher he didn't wish
for that and he was a bit of a tyrant
when things didn't go well but he's
absolutely right successes allows a
teacher but I think there is an
exception to your rule fans of the
Detroit Lions are not convinced that
losing never ends so we'll just yeah
same thing for the Jets but by the way
about a month ago when we when you
really started seeing some of the signs
of the recession could have been prior
to that you kind of give a message to
the audience out there like guys pump
the brakes on buying luxury goods Louis
Vuitton Gucci products yeah you know
let's stop buying the bags like you know
you give a warning uh to our our
gentlemen out there you know tell the
wives maybe we won't do this right
um you know you put up Tyler is there is
this ironic you have this up right now
the crypto collapse has flooded the mark
yeah we're watching with Rolex and Patek
exactly so I actually had a conversation
with a good buddy of mine who's like the
watch guy in Miami shout out to my boy
Jake if you need Rolexes like he's the
guy right uh and I actually texted him I
was like I just want to check like is my
boy he's getting married soon I'm just
checking in with him I said what's the
state of the watch Market what is
because the guy's made a freaking
killing there's no way you're buying a
high-end watch we'll see about that PVD
um but he I said what's the the stock uh
what's the status of the watch Market
you know is it correlated with what
you're seeing in crypto and real estate
in stock Market which is obviously
taking a big hit he says quote unquote
the watch Market is more of an
indication of a correction first it's
the first luxury good to weaken the
first all right I saw this at the
beginning of March and I've adjusted
accordingly it's not someone it's not
something someone needs so it's the
first to go that's right so we're
starting to see it basically what you
recommended
shedding this excess luxuries from your
life to slim down essentially what he's
saying yeah and by the way the the one
of the uh Daytona watches the one of the
Rolexes went up from thirty five
thousand dollars to 240 during the
pandemic it's down to 190. still it's
from three of those numbers again it
went from 35 to 240. it's down to 190
today okay it's still down it's still
one night but it was 45 from 35 to 240
to 190. 24 months yeah in 24 months wow
this watch was uh it's it's uh it's it's
a it's a different economy we're gonna
find out that what's going to happen
with uh people spending again like the
point is
there are so many markers like you know
how what do they say you know if you if
your left side of your chest hurts you
start having certain feelings in your
left arm and your left leg what sign is
that it might be a stroke okay so it's a
stroke or heart attack okay would you
say angina right oh yeah
sorry
no no angina okay so but but the point
is the point is like you know you know
how you come home you eat you drink a
lot okay if you drink a lot of alcohol
and you eat a lot of pizza you don't
know what are you gonna feel like in the
morning when you wake up [ __ ]
if you go drink six cups of coffee
except if your name is Mario
yeah crashing right the weirdest thing
about this economy is there are so many
indicators that are showing towards what
should happen that we're not gonna know
if it's gonna happen or not this is this
is the thing about this economy today
that's very weird that's got everybody
confused because nobody really knows
exactly what's gonna happen even with
that even with you not having a clue
what's going to be happening your job is
still to figure out your own prediction
and preparing for that and then
persevering through these bad times no
matter what's going on you have to make
your own set of predictions so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign